[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today just a a
little over a month ago back in October
we went down to DC yes because it was
the beginning of this whole student
loans are coming back the payments back
the interest is hitting and it is
affecting Americans and so we wanted to
get a pulse on really how this is
affecting people on the streets taking
it to the streets like Michael McDonald
said we were able to interview folks in
DC we went to the Georgetown area we
went all around getting people's take on
how the student loan pause and payments
coming back is affecting people so we
want to kind of show you a compilation
of what we
[Music]
heard did you have to get student aid to
come here yes I'm on financial aid got
like a work study job but um yeah yeah
they'll they'll C up for sure no you did
not Mom and Dad yes way to go Mom and
Dad yeah I I came in with a scholarship
from elsewhere so they pay for all my
stuff so you're full ride yeah full ride
up top dude that's what I'm talking
about I do have uh loans for my graduate
school from school how much do you have
already uh I'm a freshman I can't
remember the first semester number but
it's not it's not cheap it's like in the
thousands yes it's about like
$350,000 hold on one second I'm going to
have to get down here and breathe I
think I get about like uh 20,000 20,000
and do you know how much of that is aone
uh I believe about half of it half of it
so maybe 40,000 over the four years are
now your parents going to help you pay
that yes are you going to have to pay
any of it back at all um likely not I'm
feel like I'm pretty lucky that my par
able to help out a lot with that uh I
mean hopefully I'm going in a spot we
kind of share the burden but I mean
realistically we'll we'll see about that
the government has like like kind of
like a program where they calculate um
it's like an income driven repayment
plan honestly uh had an opportunity to
get into the income uh driven repayment
option so I'm a little eased that it's
maybe a reasonable payment that I can
afford uh however with the interest
securing it's already accured $1,000 in
one month before I even made an actual
payment if you had to guess just if you
said you know what Jade I think it's
probably going to take x amount of years
for me to pay off this debt in full or
if you even plan to pay it off tell me a
little bit about that I mean I'm going
to be completely honest I have no
earthly idea but I mean for the first
few years we going to be on the on the
struggle train a little bit on The
Struggle Bus as a resident I'll probably
have like a payment of about like $200
but like you know $200 when the total is
probably $400,000 and the interest is
still accumulating and that's only like
a drop in the bucket every year exactly
what does it due to you emotionally to
be thinking about $350,000 worth of
debt it's I mean right now I mean I'm
under so much stress and pressure that I
kind of put it all to the side yeah it's
outside out of mind cuz you're already
in med school and it's pressure enough
exactly I mean going off and finishing
school and kind of like restarting your
life in a lot of ways is so much
pressure on anyone so imagining having
all that debt on your shoulders is just
like an unbelievable extra burden like
you're essentially going to be working
for the next it could be the rest of
your life right to pay that off and like
it's just kind of crazy to expect a
22-year-old to you know have that much
foresight
[Music]
do you think tuition is outsized it's
gotten ridiculous what are your thoughts
on this 100% the government was giving
more loans it it raised the the cap of
the the loans that were available so as
a result a lot of colleges and
universities just increased their
tuition and the people that are paying
the price are the students yeah pretty
absurd even though like someone who's
very lucky like I am just like ask
asking someone to pay 80k a year is
pretty ridiculous I think it's an
unfortunate way to capture people in
debt it's not affordable for most people
they've been allowed to do this forever
it's it's what they do it's what we've
allowed to happen I mean I'm curious
like why has it gone up so much what do
you think about how tuition has gone up
12% a year for the last 10 years what do
you think about that as a student is it
worth it I mean honestly I love going to
school here but like you think about it
once you actually start thinking about
the real money about going here and like
you could get a similar education
obviously at a lot of other universities
and there are a lot of like
opportunities afforded to us here but I
think that for a lot of people whose
parents can't help them as much as I'm
fortunate that my parents can help me
going out into the real world after
college and having that much like debt
on your shoulders is just a lot and I
think for a lot of people it might not
be worth it it's obviously not in your
favor at all and you probably like die
still paying back it
say certainly worth it you think so and
more so beyond the academic benefit um
but the value of you know a social
community did you hear about Biden and
the Forgiveness the student loan
forgiveness and then the Supreme Court
shut it down are you familiar with that
yeah what are your thoughts on that
honestly I feel like a lot of things
like that like may appear to be
something good that a politician is
doing but in reality I don't think
anything to that extent would ever go
through just because you know he wants
to seem like he's doing all this stuff
for students for young people but in
reality that's never going to happen I
mean personally I lean pretty left so I
say yeah the government should have a
say in that but I know like some of my
fellow classmates might not think the
same it is the responsibility of
students that take up the loan to repay
it back at some point I know it probably
does suck but you took on the loan and
took on the education hopefully you had
a great plan afterwards to earn enough
income to pay it back I think it's
complete political blasphemy it's in to
his a portion of his base and I think
that obviously gained political
attaction but I think it's infeasible
and for the people who have paid off
their loans I it's it's a poor lesson
teaching I think there are people who
have busted their to repay their loans
and they're just off the hook yeah I'm
kind of conflicted in this I believe
that people should be responsible um for
you know for the the deaths that taken
out and they need to be accountable for
that on the other hand my selfish side I
would like student loan forgiveness for
sure honestly um uh as an educator I'm
disappointed I I was looking forward to
just being able to start new uh fresh uh
looking forward to purchasing my first
home uh so it's definitely it's
disappointing we have a responsibility
to help what's fair what's not fair I
don't I don't have that answer um is it
fair I understand people are like okay
well you forgive mine well you know and
someone else is like whoa hold on a
second while my take may be that the
government should be the one who fixes
this problem I think again at the
Baseline we can all agree that the
problem needs to be fixed the government
we need to do better we need to do
better in this country to help educate
our people yeah the youth have no idea
when they're signing they don't know
what $100,000 is they don't know what
$200,000 is so not to mention the
interests yeah I mean you have to be
very smart with your choices and live
within your means and uh yeah have a
plan to repay it change is going to
happen if we change and say enough no
more our youth our people deserve better
what if I told you that I paid off
$280,000 of debt I would ask you how did
you do it and can you teach me does it
give you hope though does it make you
feel like it can be possible AB
absolutely
[Music]
wow wow wow wow look if you were
listening on podcast you need to head
over to the ramsy Show YouTube and watch
that because it's totally different it's
different when you watch it and uh
honestly if you're looking for more
information about this I want you guys
to go to ramsy solutions.com
studentloans because here's the thing
the new cycle moved on Ken the new cycle
went on and they're talking about I
don't know what they're talking about
again but the pain of this is still
affecting people every single day people
are making payments they're still deeply
deeply in debt and we just want to know
we still see you guys and we're still
here for you and at the end of the day
there's still a way out and there's a
way to avoid them hey real quick we'll
help you get out of it financially but
here's a two-part question is a degree
and the loans that come with it the only
way to get where you want to go or is it
the best way if the answer is no to
either one hey go get you a certific C
ifate go get you a community college
associate degree you can get where you
want to go without the degree many times
and by the way that means no debt so
let's think about that as well create
your free every dollar budget today the
simplest way to budget for your life